Den boys
die
P
noch
die
So, da bin ich 10 Minuten später als geplant, aber es gibt ein schlimmeres, oah, oah, oah,
meine Güte.
So, ich muss erstmal kurz die Klimaanlage anmachen, hier drin ist 27°C, das geht eigentlich
noch.
26°C geht ja noch, eigentlich ist es genau genommen 26,8°C.
Ja, ich glaube ich mache da auch mal die Klimaanlage an.
Das war echt eine gute Idee vor ein paar Jahren, das Teil einbauen zu lassen.
Ist geil, was ich machen sollte ohne Klimaanlage.
Habt ja nicht mal den ganzen Tag laufen, aber ab und zu einfach mal die Hitze hier aus dem
Raum raus ist schon nicht verkehrt.
Das geht doch mega schnell, ja, die machst du an, es kommt sofort kalte Luft, also das
hat quasi überhaupt keine Anlaufzeit, das geht instant.
Nein, die läuft nicht mit Gas, die läuft mit Strom.
Die kann kühlen und heizen, wobei ich glaube ich noch nie geheizt habe, aber ich, also
ich habe es schon mal aus Versehen eingeschaltet und es funktioniert, aber benutzt habe ich
noch nie.
Aber wer weiß, wenn das mit dem Gas im Winter nicht funktioniert, muss ich mit der Klimaanlage
heizen.
Kann ja durchaus sein.
Ja, ich habe es schon mal aus Versehen eingeschaltet, aber ich habe es schon mal aus Versehen
eingeschaltet.
Aber ich habe es schon mal aus Versehen eingeschaltet.
Ich habe es schon mal aus Versehen eingeschaltet.
Also ich kann wenigstens dann im Winter heizen, wenn das mit Gas Probleme gibt.
Aber ey, dieses Thema, echt, kann es keinem erzählen.
Es ist vor ein paar Jahren gesagt, die hat mich für bescheuert gehalten und ich find's
immer noch bescheuert.
Naja, gut.
Irgendwie stehe ich mit dem Stuhl auf dem RZ-Kabel.
Moment, so.
Excellent.
Ja, mache ich auch.
Wenn ich die Tür hier zumache, beide Desktop-Rechner anhab, die Tür vom Serverraum oder vom Abstellraum mit dem Rack aufmache,
dann ist wahrscheinlich auch ohne, vermute ich jetzt einfach mal, auch ohne Heizung,
halt wenn die Tür zu ist, dann auf kurze Zeit recht warm.
Chat ist cool.
Ich übertreibe es nicht.
Heute, heute ist ganz normaler Sonntag Aufwachstream.
Wir labern bisschen, gucken uns Sachen auf YouTube an oder irgendwelche anderen Dinger.
So zwei, drei Stunden lang, so bis Mittagessen.
Ja, Zusammenschnitte gibt es ab und zu mal, wenn es irgendwas gibt, wo ich denke, dass sich das eignet.
Aktuell fällt mir da nichts ein.
Da müsste ich wieder mal irgendwie ein bisschen was auspacken und erzählen.
Aber ich weiß gerade nicht was.
Es ergibt sich ja meistens eher spontan, wenn ich irgendwas sehe im Stream und dann,
mit der Meinung bin, ich musste jetzt eine halbe Stunde darüber erzählen.
Das weiß ich im Vorfeld nicht.
So, mal kurz gucken, ob es wieder irgendwelche Sponsoring und Werbungsanfragen gibt.
Wisst ihr, was wieder am Start ist?
Hi Max, ich erhiel leider keine Reaktion von dir auf die Anfrage zu Raid Shadow Legends.
Aber das ist auch in Ordnung.
Dennoch würden wir gerne mit dir in Kontakt treten.
Die sind echt unglaublich hartnäckig.
Ich habe bestimmt von zehn unterschiedlichen Werbeagenturen Anfragen zu Raid bekommen.
Sie sind unglaublich umtriebig auch noch dazu.
Ich mache kein Raid.
Am besten waren die Typen, die geschrieben haben.
Max, bist du es auch immer leid, Werbung von Raid Shadow Legends zu bekommen,
wo das Spiel gelobt wird?
Und dann im nächsten Satz stand, wir auch.
Deshalb können wir dir jetzt Werbung anbieten für Raid Shadow Legends.
So singen wir richtig komische Mail.
Die ersten zwei Sätze waren nur dazu da, dass du die Mail liest.
Der Rest war im Prinzip genau das gleiche.
Richtig debatet.
Jetzt kann man mal was gucken.
iOS.
Alter, warum hat das 4,7 Sterne?
Warum?
Und warum ist das unterschiedlich?
Dieses Review, das hat doch garantiert keiner einfach so geschrieben.
Das ist doch irgendein schreibenden Review mit mindestens 100 Worten.
Und dann bekommst du in-game Währung oder so.
Oder aber, oder aber es ist eigentlich, weil ansonsten.
Das ist doch irgendein, das ist doch alles beschiss.
Gibt es den Coin Master eigentlich noch?
Coin Master, iOS.
Der Coin Master hat 4,7.
Adventure.
Zweiter Platz in Adventure.
Alter, Mobile Games ist einfach der absolute, komplette Abschaum.
Wie das einfach eine halbe Million Ratings hat.
Mobile Games ist so ein Rotz.
Es gibt auch Leute, die verteidigen das alles.
Es gibt genauso gut Leute, die Diablo Immortal verteidigen.
Ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass es Leute gibt, die das mögen.
Ich meine, warum spielt man Coin Master?
Ich meine ernsthaft, wenn ihr die Bilder seht.
Wenn ihr diese Bilder seht, sieht das für euch irgendwie aus, dass ihr euch denkt.
Hoi, das ist aber mal ein Game, das muss ich ausprobieren.
Version History.
Guck mal.
Coin Master bekommt mehr Patches und Fixes als Battlefield 2042.
Facebook Boomer lieben dieses Spiel, das glaube ich nicht.
Ich bin auch vom Alter her an Facebook Boomer und ich hasse solche Games.
Moment, es gibt wirklich ein Guide, wie man eine Switch aufsetzt.
Boah, eine Switch einschalten ist schon wirklich ganz schön Hexenwerk.
Naja, vielleicht weil die Leute denken, sie können Geld in irgendeiner Art und Weise machen oder gewinnen damit.
Aber ich meine, der Coin Master, das ist ja quasi Glücksspiel, ohne dass du noch die Chance hast, was ausgezahlt zu bekommen.
Also ich kann diese ganzen vor allem, ihr müsst euch mal.
Aha, Weep Games sind am Start.
Plants vs. Zombies 2, so so.
Ne, welche Kategorie müssen wir da gucken?
Best Selling müssen wir schauen.
Da sind diese ganzen Mobile Games dabei, wo jedes Logo aus...
Wie komme ich in die App Store?
Ach, keine Ahnung, die Apple Webseite ist wirklich keckel.
Guck mal, ich kriege mein eigenes Video empfohlen.
China Krams.
Oh, wieder mein eigenes Video.
Ne, ne, ist gut jetzt.
Will ich mal ein eigenes Video gucken.
So, was hat uns der YouTube zu empfehlen, zeige ich mal her.
Schon wieder mein eigenes Video.
Der Preis Champion gibt es gar nicht mehr, aber Hauptsache du empfiehlst mir jetzt das Video, YouTube.
Scheitert die Legalisierung doch noch.
Ja, was ist eigentlich mit Legalisierung?
Das wurde ja erzählt, dass man das jetzt machen will, aber irgendwie hat sich da jetzt seit einem Jahr nichts getan.
Mir ist es eigentlich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich gleichgültig, ob das passiert oder nicht.
Aber diese Sache mit ankündigen und dann nichts machen ist halt mittlerweile schon Standard.
Was wirklich mit unserem Müll passiert?
Er landet wahrscheinlich alles auf der gleichen Müllhalde, egal ob getrennt oder nicht.
Und verdient der Leiter einer frische Theke.
Ich weiß nicht, der CEO oder der CTO auf frische Theke.
Lass uns eine Runde Level Capture baiten, würde ich sagen.
Der wird eh das Gleiche sagen, wie immer.
Wenn in dem Thumbnail, ich muss mal kurz das Thumbnail von dem Video angucken.
Wenn in dem Thumbnail steht irgendwie so was wie huge and massive battlefield changes oder sowas.
Ich wusste es alle.
Dies ist immer der gleiche Grad.
Es ist schon echt ziemlich predictable alles mittlerweile.
Immer der gleiche Kram.
Was 10 Gigabit.
10 Gigabit Overcut 5e Will it work?
Höchstwahrscheinlich, solange die Strecke nicht so groß ist.
Also die YouTube Empfehlung heute sind ja auch mal wieder komplett Banane.
How programmers prepare for a job interview.
Okay, das kann man nachher gucken.
Das ist doch auch der Typ, der irgendwie.
If programming was an anime, der dieses Video gemacht hat mit Programming Semper.
What your favorite programming language says about you.
See, you prefer stability and simplicity.
Naja, Stability kann man sich jetzt fragen.
Ich mein C an sich schon das, was du damit programmierst.
Nicht zwangsläufig Java.
Kotlin.
You work in game development on Microsoft?
Nee, ich verwende es auch so.
OOP ist ja auch okay.
Versucht mal in GO OOP zu machen.
Oder versucht mein GO ordentlich was zu kapseln oder irgendwie sinnvoll zusammen auszulagern.
Das ist gar nicht mal so einfach, was kein Funktion overloading.
Du hast keine gescheiten Klassen, du hast keine ordentlichen private public modifier.
Also man kann man kann Objektorientierung sicherlich total übertreiben.
Mit einem Klassen diagramm irgendwie 50 layer die.
Aber man kann es auch sinnvoll verwenden.
Ja, gut, keine Ahnung, ob das auf Rastprogrammierer zutrifft.
Aber die Chance ist wahrscheinlich recht hoch bei Rastprogrammieren.
Kann schon sein, kann ich mir die Kombination durchaus vorstellen.
Ich verstehe den PAP-Hate gar nicht.
PAP ist doch absolut in Ordnung.
Was ist denn das?
Erlang?
Nee, Haskell ist das, oder? Was ist das?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Portran.
Aber YouTube Empfehlungen für Videos sind heute irgendwie etwas pepeger.
Easy und cheap VPN sollen wir uns angucken, sagt er.
Das ist wahrscheinlich F1 WireGuard, oder?
Ich würde jetzt mal tippen.
Moin.
Ja moin Leute.
Schön, dass ihr alle da seid.
Ist doch gar nicht richtig großartig Chat geguckt.
Pog? Massive Pog? Giga Pog?
Gibt es sowas? Giga Pog als Emote? Bestimmt.
Naja, es gibt bessere Emotes.
Leute, ihr under-used neue Emotes, die ich eingefügt habe.
Zum Beispiel das hier.
Das ist wirklich critically under-used.
Es ergibt auch wenig Sinn, warum man es usen sollte.
Aber ich finde die Kombination so geil.
Man kann es ja mehrdeutig verstehen an dem Fall.
Oder dem Typ auf dem Klo.
Auch 5000 Euro Klo.
Geht Way to Dank eigentlich mittlerweile?
Way to Dank funktioniert, alles klar.
Hat gestern ja bloß irgendwie drei Stunden gedauert, bis es funktioniert.
Also, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, manche Videos bekommen eher wegen dem Vorschaubild, die vielen Views.
Nicht unbedingt wegen dem Content.
Mit diesen CPUs will Intel AMD schlagen.
Was ist eigentlich mit Intel los?
Warum heißt der ganze Cremple eigentlich seit Jahren irgendwas mit Lake?
Bei AMD war es früher so, oder vielleicht ist es bei Intel auch so, ich weiß es nicht.
Bei AMD war es früher so, dass die CPUs immer hießen wie irgendwelche Orte um den AMD Sitz.
Keine Ahnung, wie das bei Intel ist.
Kann man nicht vorstellen, dass es ein Raptor Lake bei Intel irgendwie gibt.
Weil sie dort ihr Geld versenken.
Ja, eher deins.
Untersee-Kabel ohne Kabel, kein Internet.
Wir Trace-Routen durch die Welt.
Wo Trace-Routet er dann hin?
Er Trace-Routet, ja.
Kann man machen.
Weiß ich nicht genau, warum man das machen soll, aber kann man machen.
Ich finde das witzig, dass Pi-Hole immer noch in Videos angekündigt werden kann, als wäre es was Neues.
Das hat doch echt mittlerweile jeder mitbekommen, oder, dass es sowas gibt.
Das ist einmal einfach nicht Call of Duty.
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich ein Nachbau von irgendeinem Map, oder?
Aber relativ gut nachgemacht.
20 Stealth-Camping-Tipps and Skills.
Genau das wollte ich mir jetzt angucken.
Stealth-Camping.
Ist Stealth-Camping die Umschreibung für das, was Penner in Frankfurt machen?
Ist das auch Stealth-Camping?
Wobei, die sind nicht Stealth, die sind offensichtlich.
Warum ist das Toss?
Geht mal nach Frankfurt.
Lauf vom Hauptbahnhof raus, links rum.
Ne, da Straße, geht da mal durch.
Das ist kein Stealth-Camping, ne, das ist...
Ja, wir liegen einfach so auf der Straße rum.
Na gut, also, die YouTube-Empfehlungen diesmal sind jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn heute.
Ja, aber nur die Videos dazu, selbst auch nicht.
Ich werde es mir auch nicht angucken, weil ich absolut keine Ahnung habe, wofür man das sinnvollerweise verwenden sollte.
Zumal ich die Sündtags auch ein bisschen merkwürdig finde, was ich gesehen habe, aber das kann auch sein, dass man sich da dran gewöhnen, das doch ganz gut ist.
Aber ich verstehe den Einsatzzweck nicht.
Was ist das?
Carbon ist ein Aufsatz.
Ne, Aufsatz ist falsch.
Ist eine C++-kompatible Sprache von Google, wo ich nicht weiß, warum man die verwenden sollte.
Außer man ist Google und wir hier gerade dabei sind.
Da können wir uns das noch gerade mal angucken.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wer man das verwenden soll.
Warum man das verwenden soll, außer man ist Google und man hasst C++, hat aber so viele C++-Libraries, ohne die man nicht leben kann.
So, das ist das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen kann.
Ich glaube, normale Leute, für die bringt Carbon gar nichts.
Was sagen die hier dazu?
Von dem habe ich tatsächlich auch schon ein paar Talks geguckt.
Das ist der In-Compiler-Dude.
Also YouTube-Empfehlungen sind heute wirklich ziemlich pains-champ.
Also, dann lassen wir uns mal eine Runde Level-Capture-Baden.
Also ist C++ ein Sub-Set auf Carbon?
Ne, die Sprache hat komplett andere Syntax.
Sie ist bloß insofern kompatibel zu C++, dass das, was rauskommt, von C++ benutzt werden kann und C++-Sachen in Carbon benutzt werden kann.
Die Syntax selbst dürfte nicht kompatibel sein.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du einfach C++ nehmen kannst und in den Carbon-File pasten und das kompiliert.
Okay, also Level-Capture-Bade uns.
LEAKT!
Ob das jemals rauskommt?
Weil die machen so viel Geld mit GTA 5, warum sollten die GTA 6 rausbringen?
Weil das ist ja auch ein gewisses Risiko.
Stell euch mal vor, GTA 5 bringt massig Kohle.
Die bringen GTA 6 raus und GTA 6 sollte wirklich nicht so gut ankommen.
Und dann haben die Leute ja keinen Bock weiter GTA 5 zu spielen, dann verlieren die Geld?
Äh, kurze KeckW-Frei.
Generation Z-Frei, glaubst du, wir werden irgendwann uns auf TikTok im Stream sp-
NO GOD!
NO GOD PLEASE NO!
Auf der anderen Seite, warum nicht?
Warum nicht, warum nicht?
Okay, dann schickt mir mal, da müsst ihr mich jetzt von überzeugen, Leute, da müsst ihr mich von überzeugen.
Schickt mir mal einen richtig guten TikTok-Content, Technik, Gaming, was auch immer, den ich geil finden werde.
Also nicht Bubageil, sondern der mir gefällt.
Dann schick, dann guck ich mir das an und wenn mir das gefällt, dann vielleicht, vielleicht gucken wir uns dann auf TikTok an.
Okay, also Level Cap, tschiebe ich uns.
Ach ja, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Sekunde, einmal kurz refreshen.
Okay, die Players sind wieder runter um die Hälfte vom Release.
Das ist der erste Season.
Ich mein, man darf nicht vergessen, die erste Season ist ja überhaupt schwierig Season zu nennen.
Der Map-Release nach über einem halben Jahr.
Okay.
TikTok.
Projekt ist fertig.
Darf man das blocken, ohne dass es einem auf dem Keks geht?
Ist das, ist das, ist das irgendwie Knoblauchsoße als CPU-Kühler?
Zahnpasta als Wärmeleitpaste, kennt ja mittlerweile schon jeder, aber kennt ihr schon Knoblauchsoße als Wärmeleitpaste?
Also langsam tut mir die CPU...
Leute, Premiere, ich hab noch nie ein TikTok-Video seit vier Jahren auf Twitch geguckt.
Tut euch ein bisschen leid, aber egal.
Lecker Knoblauchsoße auf der...
But why?
Doch, ich weiß, wie du drauf gekommen bist.
Du hast dir gedacht, wir können mal ein cooles TikTok-Video machen, was die Leute angucken werden.
Das ist nicht, dass du das jetzt irgendwie machst, um wirklich was Sinnvolles damit zu machen.
Das ist rein für das Video.
Find ich, hab ich kein Problem mit, kann man schon machen, ja.
Zahnpasta gibt's schon lange, ja.
Ja, okay, das ist ein uralt Rechner, das ist irgendwie Pentium 4 oder sowas.
Natürlich geht das.
Und wenn du das Ding nicht großartig belasten wirst, wird's auch weiter funktionieren.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es sogar unter Volllast eine Weile funktioniert.
Aber ich gehe halt davon aus, dass die jetzt nicht unbedingt jetzt Langzeitbeständig ist und gut funktioniert.
Ich muss den Bildschirm wechseln, weil der andere irgendwie in die Binsen gegangen ist.
Also ja, die Temperaturen völlig in Ordnung, nur lauwarme 80 bis 90 Grad im Eidl.
Das Ding ist jetzt zwei Minuten an und lustigerweise riecht schon der gesamte Raum nach Knoblauch.
Ach, Knoblauch. Ja, wer hätte das gedacht?
Die Temperaturen haben sich ein bisschen normalisiert, hatten gerade ein Minimum von 61 Grad, aber natürlich immer noch im Eidl.
Ich hab irgendwie ein bisschen Angst, dass wenn ich jetzt Cinebench starte, das ganze Ding einfach explodiert.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, Cinebench funktioniert auch ohne Probleme.
Nur halt auf Dauer nicht.
Zumal im Zweifelsfall taktet sich die CPU runter.
Obwohl, das ist so ein altes Ding.
Nee, ist gar nicht so alt.
Das ist ein i5.
Dann taktet die sich runter, da passiert gar nichts.
Aber wir machen es trotzdem.
Also ja, wir sind eigentlich direkt auf 100 Grad durchgehend.
CPU taktet sofort runter.
Wir sind direkt im Thermal Throttling.
Ja, Knoblauchsoße ist wohl dann doch nicht so das Wahre.
Und da die CPU schöne 100 Grad erreicht hat, ist hier drin wirklich ein herrlicher Duft.
Ja, so sieht das Ganze dann aus.
Irgendwie sieht es...
Ein bisschen verbrannt aus.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Und was lernen wir daraus, meine lieben Freunde?
Gar nichts.
Also die letzten zwei Sekunden dürften jedes TikTok-Video ziemlich gut zusammenfassen.
Was lernen wir daraus?
Gar nichts.
Das ist wahrscheinlich relevant oder gültig für 95% aller TikTok-Videos.
Allerdings auch für die meisten YouTube-Videos, muss man auch ehrlich sagen.
Die haben das schon 2009 gemacht.
Ja, das ist nichts Neues.
Wie gesagt, ich habe schon die Zahnpasterexperimente gesehen.
Ich habe schon Zahnpasterexperimente gesehen, schon vor Urzeiten.
Passten im Extremtest.
PC Games Hardware in Gefahr.
Von 2009.
Ja, das war damals krasser Production Value.
Seit Millionen von Jahren verkaufen uns die Hersteller überteuerte Wärmeleitpaste.
Doch leitet beispielsweise Zahnpaste oder Ketchup nicht mindestens genauso gut.
Hier sehen Sie die auserwählten Testkandidaten, wie beispielsweise die NVIDIA-Creme mit dem...
Also die...
Ist das... Ach, das ist Honig, dachte das Erdnussbutter.
Codenamen Nivea.
Gleitcreme testen wir dieses Mal nicht, da sich kein Kollege bereit erklärt hat, ein entsprechendes Mittel auszuleihen.
Den CPU-Lüfter schließen wir direkt an einem 12-Volt-Adapter an, um eine automatische Lüftersteuerung zu vermeiden.
Mit Prime95 sorgen wir für 100%...
Das ist auch cool, oder?
Dass man 2009 Prime95 verwendet hat und dass man 2022 immer noch Prime95 verwendet.
... Prozent CPU-Last, um den Prozessor aufzuheizen.
Bei diesem ersten Test haben wir keine Wärmeleitpaste aufgetragen,
um die Effizienz von Honig und Co. später besser beurteilen zu können.
Die Musik im Hintergrund!
Da jetzt nach einer Minute liegt die CPU-Temperatur bei 66°C.
Der höchste Wert wird nach etwa 4 Minuten erreicht.
Moment, ist da jetzt Wärmeleitpaste drauf oder gar nichts?
Für gar nichts bleibt das Ding ganz schön kühl.
Das bleibt erstaunlich kühl für gar nichts!
Im nächsten Test muss die MX-2 Wärmeleitpaste von Articooling zeigen,
ob die Konkurrenz nicht vielleicht doch besser kühlt und zudem besser riecht.
Das war schön, die Wärmeleitpaste draufgespachtelt.
Ganz ohne Paste erhöhte sich die CPU-Temperatur auf 71°C.
Ja, das war aber nur 50°C.
Wobei, ich glaube, die Core 2 Duos durften damals gar nicht so warm werden wie heute.
Heute dürfen die Dinger bis 105°C oder um die 105°C bis sie sich runtertakten.
Ich glaube, damals war es weniger.
Diese Musik im Hintergrund!
Jetzt noch die Bauer, die die Auer-Wärmeleitpaste.
Ach, die gab es damals noch nicht, ja.
Mit einem speziellen Mittel reinigen wir nun CPU und die Kupferfläche.
Schließlich wollen wir nicht, dass die Rückstände in Verbindung mit Zahnpaste
zu einer chemischen und explosiven Reaktion führen.
Das Auftragen funktioniert schon mal prima.
Ach, viel zu viel, oder?
Und klappt viel besser als bei der MX2-Paste.
Die Zahnpaste zeigt eindrucksvoll, dass die Temperatur nur langsam ansteigt.
Nach etwa 4 Minuten messen wir lediglich 3°C mehr...
Siehste?
Wozu richtige Wärmeleitpaste kaufen?
Außerdem riecht es dann im Zimmer nach Pfefferminz oder was auch immer man hat.
...als mit der Articooling-Paste.
Wärmeleitpaste ist bloated.
Nach 10 Minuten pendelt sich der Wert sogar noch etwas niedriger ein.
Also Ketchup kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das gut funktioniert.
Der Vorteil von Zahnpaste wird erst jetzt deutlich.
Durch die hohe Temperatur entsteht eine Wärmeleitpad ähnliche Masse,
die sich allerdings auch schwer entfernen lässt.
Das Ding möchte ich nicht auf meiner CPU haben.
Ob Ketchup noch besser kühlt?
Oh, viel zu viel, Alter!
Wenn er da den Lüfter drauf macht, dann ist er das halbe Mainboard voller Ketchup.
Bemengen müssen wir lediglich die Handhabung.
Hey, funktioniert richtig gut!
Besser als die offizielle echte Wärmeleitpaste!
Alter, was für eine Saurei!
Das würde ich nicht!
Nivea!
Die arme CPU, was da alles schon aufs Mainboard gekleckert ist!
Mit maximal 55 Grad Celsius platziert sich die Creme nur ganz knapp
hinter der Profi Wärmeleitpaste von Arctic Cooling.
Im letzten Test muss ein klebriger Honig zeigen,
ob er als Wärmeleitpaste verbraucht.
Das kriegst du wahrscheinlich nie wieder aus den Ritzen da von der CPU.
Drumherum raus!
Obwohl auch hier Geruchsstoffe freigesetzt wurden,
mussten wir nach dem Test keine Vergiftung davontragen.
Geht auch!
Funzt alles!
Die Musik im Hintergrund, oder?
Denkst du wunderbar, was abgeht?
Na, Langzeit kannst du das vergessen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich großbeständig ist auf Dauer da drunter.
Vor allem ist halt die Frage, ob die Dinger das aushalten.
Heiß, dann schaltest du aus.
Kalt, nächsten Tag wieder heiß.
Das wird wahrscheinlich verkrusten nach spätestens ein paar Tagen
und nicht mal gescheit funktionieren.
Das sie prinzipiell alles verwenden können.
Nur komplett auf Wärmeleitpaste verzichten sollten sie keinesfalls.
Damit an den Testresultaten keine Zweifel aufkommen,
haben wir zum Schluss einen zweiten Test ohne Wärmeleitpaste gemacht
und sind auf das exakt gleiche Ergebnis gekommen.
Den Testsieg haben wir diesem qualitativ hochwertigen Markenketchup von Heinz zu verdanken.
Über einen Test von weiteren Ketchup-Sorten...
Ist das Cell-Out?
Ist das ein Cell-Out?
...denken wir nun eventuell nach.
An dieser Stelle noch ein wichtiger Hinweis.
War das ein gut versteckter Cell-Out?
Mit Heinz-Tomatenketchup?
Sowas gab's.
Warum?
Sie hatten damals auch schon eine Werbung im Magazin.
Natürlich.
Warum sollten die nicht sowas auch in ihren Videos gemacht haben?
Okay, jetzt lassen wir uns erstmal Level-Cap fertig zubäden.
Oh!
Nach acht Monaten haben sie Kisten hingestellt.
Krasser Scheiß-Dice!
Boah, ihr seid absoluter Wahnsinn!
Ihr habt's wirklich geschafft, in acht Monaten da zwei Kisten zu platzieren.
Wie machen die das, Leute?
Ich will das auch können.
Wie machen die das?
Das ist ja wirklich Lex-Level-Produktivität.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr schafft es wirklich.
In acht Monaten.
Überlegt euch mal.
Ihr schafft es in acht Monaten von so zu so.
Das kann nicht sein.
Unmöglich.
Drei Betonblöcke auf die Map in acht Monaten.
Das ist nicht schaffbar.
Wie machen die das?
Da!
Und dann auch noch hier oben eine Kiste hingestellt.
Das Überstunden-Crunch-Time.
Guck mal, da war vorher keine Kiste.
Da war jetzt eine Kiste.
Alter, ist das heftig.
Rohstoffmangel, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahnsinn, was die alles können bei da.
Guck mal hier.
Hier ist nix.
Und jetzt steht da ein Auto.
Und Sandsäcke.
Meine Güte.
Und noch ein paar Container.
Wahnsinn.
Okay, das geht ja tatsächlich.
Was, Falk?
Ach, Falk.
Zu Falk?
Was? Welcher Charakter heißt denn Falk?
Nein, nein, die meinen den Medic.
Huge Aim.
Nein, nein.
What?
Was zum?
Ja, ja, ist klar.
Über ein VPN-Spielen ist mit Sicherheit viel, viel besser für alles, ja.
Über ein VPN-Spielen ist wahrscheinlich zumindest das Bescheuertste, was du machen kannst.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen, es bringt dir ja auch nix.
Ist das Sellout, oder?
Ich wollte ja auch mal Sellout machen für NordVPN, habe ich glaube ich jetzt schon ein paar Mal erzählt.
Und wir waren uns sogar einig, was wir machen.
Ja, also Geld und was ich sagen soll und so, hatten wir uns schon drauf geeinigt.
Und auf einmal meinten die Leute.
Max, damit wir das machen können, musst du dieses Video von deinem Channel entfernen.
Sonst können wir mit dir leider doch kein Sponsoring machen.
Da dachte ich mir so, ja, leck mich, dann machen wir kein Sponsoring.
Ja, das hat denen nicht so ganz gefallen, dass ich so ein Video mal hochgeladen habe.
Aber davon abgesehen, das Video ist ja immer noch relevant.
Okay, okay, Angel hat jetzt einen Bart, habe ich das richtig gesehen?
Und weiter?
Angel, das hätte gern.
Da hat die Welt daraus gewartet, dass Angel jetzt Gigachat ist, genau.
Ja, aber es gibtWANNT auch.
Nein, ich mich 과 переidian!
Was 좋을 man?
Ericaked.
Ein Bow.
das die Meta des Spiels schon seit der 0-Hour-Update eingeführt hat.
Bleibt aufgeregt für weitere Nachrichten und Details.
Lasst uns in den Kommentaren wissen, welche Veränderungen ihr euch vorwärts seht.
Ein neuer Mittelspiel-Update ist in Afrika rollen.
Es gibt ja keine nennenswerte Veränderungen, für die ich vorwärts schauen könnte.
Call of Duty Vanguard in Warzone auf Juli 26.
Das Update enthält ein neuer Assault-Rifle und die neue Desolation-Multiplayer-Map zu entlocken.
Ein neuer Mittelspiel-Update enthält auch neue Terminator-Bundles für die Store.
Spieler sollten Terminator-Skins für die T-800-Model und die T-1000-Model erwarten.
Die Fan-Favorite Zombie-Rarelle-Mode wird auch auf den Rebirth-Island-Map eingeführt.
Das letzte Overwatch 2 Beta endete diese Woche mit einem letzten Teaser für Fans von What's
to Come.
Ein Message-Display, als das Beta endete, sah jubelig aus, aber nach einer weiteren
Inspektion sah es aus, als ob es etwas Bedeutung gab.
Die Spieler haben schnell die Message ausgedeckt, was die Fox sagt.
Das ist der zweite Fox-Teaser.
Vorher im Jahr wurde die Fox in der Reveal-Trailer entdeckt.
Leider schadet dieses neue Teaser keine Lichtung auf die Situation.
Einige Fans glauben, dass es etwas mit Fox-Heroen zu tun hat.
Insofern habe ich Hoffnung, dass es mit Fox-Heroen wieder mehr Zuspruch findet und länger aktiv
bleibt.
Das steht und fällt damit, was Blizzard nach dem Launch macht.
Overwatch 1 haben sie ganz gut gestartet, aber dann sind sie in ein Loch gefallen, wo man
sich denkt, es kann doch nicht sein, dass alle drei Monate mal etwas Kleines kommt und zwischendurch
mal ein PDF-Comic oder so, und dass man teilweise 3-4 Monate braucht, um essentielle Dinge zu
patchen.
Ja, das geht mittlerweile ein bisschen besser, dafür gibt es kaum Content in Overwatch seit
den letzten 2,5 Jahren, 3 Jahren oder so.
Also, weiß nicht.
Hast du den neuen Battlefield 2042 Pay to Win-Skin gesehen?
Nö.
Gibt's da was?
Oficially confirmed, four games in active development have been cancelled.
Splinter Cell VR, Ghost Recon Frontline and two unannounced games are getting the plug
pulled due to an uncertain economic environment.
Ubisoft announced a remake of the original Splinter Cell game back in 2021, hopefully
this VR title is not what they were talking about.
Ghost Recon Frontlines was going to be a large-scale Battle Royale title, and had already undergone
closed out.
im Ernst, ich glaube ein weiteres Battle Royale in diesem Setting und dann von Ubisoft, ich
glaube da hat echt keiner drauf gewartet, aber gleich machen, die haben tatsächlich
die Kurve gekriegt, hätte ich am Anfang nicht vermutet, aber No Man's Sky muss wohl seit
einer Weile schon ein richtig gutes Game sein, das wird noch zu Star Citizen bevor Star Citizen
herausbekommen.
und ein neuer Modell-Viewer.
Der PlayStation 5-Controller beinhaltet eine Fähigkeit, die sich mit Motivation beherrscht.
Das macht es gut, wenn man die Spielzeuge nach dem Reihenfall der letzten Konsolengeneration
nach dem Reihenfall der letzten Konsolengeneration
aufbauen muss, um die Spielzeuge mehr immersiv zu machen.
Die Remake wird dieses Jahr auch auf September 2.
Die Entwickler der Co-Op-Zombie-Survival-Game Back4Blood
erhoben brachte erimdi den Titel, der in dieser nächsten Expansion zur K 생
裡不 clearer, die Offiz filteringesen, dass es durch mehrereousse
liege der Verhandlung hoch die nutz
Der Rest der Tweet betrifft die Expansion von Act 5 und wie es mit Kulten inspiriert wird.
Der Tweet beinhaltet auch eine Art ritualistische Führung.
Es ist unklar, wann dieses neue Content live gehen wird.
Das Game interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt nicht großartig, ich muss nämlich auch dazu sagen,
ich habe zwar die originalen Left, also Left 101, Left 102, so semi viel gespielt,
aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich so der Hardcore Fan bin, der da unbedingt einen dritten Teil von gebraucht hätte.
Also 2030 kommt es dann raus.
Also wenn ich mir die Vergangenheit von Intel und GPUs angucke, predikte ich jetzt einfach mal, da kommt nichts gescheites raus.
Zumindest nicht für uns im Heim-Gaming-Segment.
Es gab Blockchain-Sachen in Minecraft?
Ganz davon abgesehen, wenn irgendein Server der Meinung ist, er bietet Mods an und dort ist dann irgendwas NFT, was auch immer mäßiges, da können die ja nichts dagegen machen.
Ich meine, das sind Server-seitige Mods, da haben die ja nichts mit zu tun.
Ok, das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Ok, ok, ok, ich brauche ein Xbox-Headset und irgendwie Mobile und was wie sonst wie, ok, dann ist wahrscheinlich doch Crap.
Ja, das fände ich nicht schlecht, das wäre tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Ach komm on, nicht immer exakt das Gleiche sagen am Ende des Videos.
Wie sollen die das denn verhindern? Der Minecraft-Server ist doch nicht mal von Microsoft.
Minecraft-Server sind zum größten Teil irgendwelche GitHub-Open-Source-Projekte und wenn da einer irgendeinen Plugin reinhängen will mit NFTs und Blockchain und warum auch immer, um seine Spiele zu scammen, da kann er das machen, da kann Microsoft nichts dagegen tun.
BeachBuggy 2 Racing, endlich!
Aber Steam Integration ist tatsächlich immer eine coole Sache.
Ok, eine Runde LevelCapture Baited, sehr gut. Jetzt wissen wir wieder Bescheid, dass sich in Battlefield nichts getan hat. Auch wenn er immer so erzählt und tut, so huge, massive changes, real changes, unglaubliche changes und im Endeffekt sind es halt auch keine Changes, sondern es sind drei neue Kisten auf der Map.
Ok, man könnte sagen, drei neue Kisten auf der Map sind auch Changes, aber...
Technik Comedy auf TikTok, später vielleicht. Ich glaube mein Cringe Level ist noch nicht hoch genug gerade.
Immer, immer, so lange es um 2042 geht. Oder es gibt zwei Sachen, entweder C++ Rant oder Battlefield 2042 Rant.
Das schwankt immer, so je nachdem, wie es mir gerade...
Ich kann gar nichts fixen. Die müssen ein neues Game machen und dann den gut. Fertig.
Kaizo Tips, dass es immer noch Leute spielen. Das ist ein Romhack von 2005 oder so. Das ist uralt.
Ok, lass mal kurz überlegen. Was ist die dümmste Schnittstelle aller Zeiten? Ok, es gibt eigentlich eine Schnittstelle, die führt.
Das ist tatsächlich USB. Und nicht, weil USB so dumm ist. An sich ist USB ziemlich geil.
Aber was die Leute, die den Hut auf haben für den USB-Standard damit machen, ist halt abfuck.
Ansonsten die useless Schnittstelle Firewire vielleicht. Firewire oder...
Obwohl es geht ja um den dümmsten Stecker. Nicht um die dümmste Schnittstelle, sondern um den dümmsten Stecker.
Vielleicht auch Schnittstelle. Was ist die dümmste Schnittstelle, die es je gegeben hat?
Also ich mein, useless heute sind natürlich so Sachen wie Parallelport, Serialport und sowas. Aber die sind nicht dumm.
Die haben auch heute noch in manchen Anwendungen Sinn. Und Serial Communication ist ja bei Microcontrollern immer noch Standard.
Und wird es wahrscheinlich auch für immer sein. In vielen Sachen. Also...
Was könnte die dümmste? SCART. SCART ist tatsächlich richtig dumm. Ja, aber SCART ist halt nicht am PC. Ok, gucken wir mal. Was denn?
Alter, wie viele USB-Anschlüsse sind da hinten dran?
16! Was ist das für ein Board?
Ist das Doppel-Display-Port? HDMI-Display-Port-Display-Port? Na gut.
Ja, dann erzähl mal.
Also Firewire. Firewire bin ich dabei. Also Firewire war damals schon nicht so...
...und ist jetzt erst recht nett. So. Also. Komplett unsinnig.
Ja gut. Dieser Crap, diese Lightning-Stecker ist halt einfach nur weil Apple Apple ist.
Ist das, ist das, ist das die DVI-VGA-Geschichte?
Ach seh. Ach. Dann.
Na ja gut. Wenn's danach geht, irgendwelche proprietären Sachen, die relativ schnell eingestellt wurden, da gibt's ja wie Sand am Meer.
Also quasi HDMI des letzten Jahrtausends.
S-Video? Ja. Nö, das würd ich nicht sagen, dass es Crap ist. Das war zu bestimmten Zeiten, also so...
...wo es da noch Skat-Stecker gab am Fernseh und so. Gar keine schlechte Möglichkeit, was zu übertragen.
Sponsor. Sponsor. Sehr laut. Ach so.
Na ja. Funktioniert. Er funktioniert. Schön funktionieren tut er nicht.
Also es ist immer noch ziemlich abartig, da Sachen rein und rauszustecken.
Ja, also diese Connector, da hast du auch immer gerade bei der Billig-China-Variante davon, da steckst du vorne was rein und dann schiebst du hinten den Connector raus und so.
Also diese Stecker sind wirklich abfuck. Da hat er schon recht, aber ich mein, die funktionieren.
Und es ist jetzt nicht so, als müsstest du in deinem Rechner irgendwie mehrfach am Tag die SSD, wobei die SSD, ja doch, oder als müsstest du mehrfach am Tag dort irgendwas an- und abstöpseln.
Ja, ich hab mich übrigens vertan, SATA SSDs haben ja diesen kleinen Stecker, die haben ja gar nicht mehr diesen Molex-Stecker.
Also falls jemand von euch noch einen DVD-Brenner oder sowas drin hat, der hat wahrscheinlich so einen Connector.
Ja, genau, das was ich gemeint hab, da hast du dann das Ding vor hinten rausgeschoben, gerade wenn es so ein Billig-China-Chinesen-Connector war.
3,5 Zoll HDDs haben den heutzutage auch noch.
Ja, aber du kannst die meisten auch per SATA, hier nennen wir mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Seagate, irgendwie so ein Teil.
Können wir uns die Please mal von hinten angucken? Guck, die haben SATA-Power-Connector. Siehste? Die haben den SATA-Power-Connector.
Hier, den da, den langen. Also der hat nämlich auch den Vorteil, dass man die Dinge ordentlich in den Wechselrahmen stecken kann.
Und bei der Dingsbombs, danke schön für die Zeit. Micro-USB? Na ja.
Micro-USB ist doch ganz okay. Ja gut, das stimmt schon. Sonderlich widerstandsfähig waren die Dinger natürlich nicht.
Ich hab noch zwei Geräte, die haben noch Mini-USB, dafür brauch ich echt noch ein Kabel. Mein Mikrofon, mein USB-Mikro ist Mini-USB und ich hab noch eine Capture-Karte, die ist auch Mini-USB.
An sich war das schon okay. Problematisch war das nur als Ladekabel, wo man das täglich mehrfach abgemacht hat.
Man muss aber auch sagen, auch diese Lightning-Kabel, wobei die Lightning-Kabel nicht, sondern die Lade-Connector in den iPhones hatten halt auch lange Zeit Probleme, dass es nach einer Weile keinen richtigen Kontakt mehr hatte.
Da muss man es immer so biegen, dass es noch funktioniert.
Das muss man schon sagen, den Sellout haben sie immer gut drauf.
Ach, der meint die Jumper-Wire-Dingeranschlüsse für das Gehäuse.
Ja, das ist ja, wo schlimm ist es doch gar nicht.
Also so schlimm fand ich das ehrlich gesagt nie.
Das einzig Dumme ist, dass du manchmal nicht weißt, was oben und unten ist. Das liegt aber eher daran, weil die Mainboard-Hersteller den Kram nicht richtig beschrift haben.
Was ein Ding! Das kenne ich nicht.
Genau, das kommt nämlich noch dazu, das schließt er einmal an und dann bleibt es halt so.
Ja, aber kann man schon zum größten Teil zustimmen.
Das war jetzt kein komplett sinnloses Video.
Das ist auch das Thumbnail, Mann.
Hast du dich heute schon tribayen lassen? Ja, habe ich.
Ich habe Thumbnails drauf.
Ich gehe davon, das ist ganz schön viel, was in China alles gebannt ist.
Okay, was können wir uns sonst antun noch hier?
Alles klar, auf geht's.
Ah, das ist Video ohne Sound.
Excellent.
Max, kannst du mal Anti-Cheat für Battlefield 5 entwickeln? Easy mache ich in einem Nachmittag.
Hört sich an wie beim Zahnarzt.
Das ist zum Isolieren, oder? Nicht Isolieren, abdichten.
Der Cheat-Chip.
Magnete.
Kleidmittel, Gachi-Buzz.
Oh, das wird hier richtig sophisticated Konstruktion hier.
Das eine ist für vorn und rückwärts, das andere ist für links und rechts. Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Raspberry Pi Zero rein.
Das ist gar kein Zero, das ist ein... ist das ein Pico?
Nee, das ist kein Pico, das kann nicht sein, das wird was anderes draufstehen. Das ist ein Zero, ne? Ja.
Ich kann nicht gelesen, dass das Zero stand.
Das ist ein Zahnarzt, das ist ein Zahnarzt.
Das ist ein Zahnarzt.
Da steht irgendeiner rum.
Da da Sensor, weiß ich nicht, wie das ist, wie gut das durch Scheiben geht.
Also die Ultraschall-Sensoren gehen nicht durch Scheiben logischerweise.
Hey guck mal, es funktioniert.
Ich kann eine Kamera hängen, aber da muss ich auf die Kamera gucken.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich recht nice.
Das muss ich sagen, das funktioniert ja wirklich erstaunlich gut.
Das flitzt voll, guck mal, das gibt voll Gas, das Ding.
Aber die Batterie hält wahrscheinlich nicht lange.
Bisschen flach das Ganze.
Mit Kamera fragt mich, wo die Batterie für die Kamera ist.
Oder wahrscheinlich ist es in der Kamera drin.
Crash.
Oh, Tossmusik.
Aber coole Konstruktion.
Coole Konstruktion.
Also muss man sagen, das ist nicht schlecht.
Es ist halt nicht sonderlich tief.
Aber an sich, nice Konstruktion.
So, macht er das noch woanders rein?
Jagen als Beruf, Arbeit und Gehalt eines Revierjägers in den bayerischen Alpen.
Okay, das kommt jetzt.
Ich will jetzt wissen, was der Jäger verdient.
Naja, ein bisschen tiefer als 20 cm hätte es schon sein dürfen, da war es ein Pool tiefer.
Ja, was für ein Sensor kann ich denn nehmen für meinen Parkplatzsensor?
Nee, Radar Sensor.
Reichweite.
Reichweite, wie lange geht denn sowas?
200 Meter.
Das halte ich jetzt aber für.
Ja, 15, 15 und 60 cm ist deutlich zu wenig.
Ich brauche schon irgendwas, was 2, 3 Meter, das ordentlich checken kann.
Das kannst du mit einem Laser Sensor machen.
Mal gucken.
So ein Laser Sensor bei mir aber lieber.
Das stelle ich mir auch von der Handhabung einfacher vor.
Ja, das ist Laser, das ist aber ein Laser Sensor, das ist kein Radar.
Aber ja, sowas ist gut. Es ist halt die Frage, wie gut das durch die Scheibe geht.
Also es wird durch die Scheibe gehen, aber ich weiß halt nicht, wie weit es da noch geht.
Up to 4 meters.
Ja, muss man mal ausprobieren.
Weil dann kann ich wirklich checken, ob der Parkplatz vom Haus frei ist oder nicht.
Nee, Magnetsensor geht nicht. Ich meine, der Microcontroller kommt in den Keller.
Und der Parkplatz, den ich checken will, der ist halt schon so vom Kellerfenster, würde ich sagen.
2 Meter weg.
Das funktioniert nicht mit Magnet.
Und wie gut funktioniert es bei Nebel und Regen? Ja, das tatsächlich, genau das ist die Frage.
Es ist nicht so einfach.
Außerdem sind Magnetsensoren umgedreht, also du kannst nicht mit einem Magnetsensor testen, ob da Metall in der Nähe ist.
Du kannst mit einem Magnetsensor testen, ob Magnet in der Nähe ist.
So, weiter gehts.
Gucken wir uns jetzt an. Ok, der Jäger. Was verdient der Jäger? Auf gehts.
Wer wollte nicht schon immer mal Jäger werden?
Ich glaube Jäger ist auch so eines der Berufe, die würde ich dem Leben nicht machen.
Viel zu viel an der frischen Luft, Alter.
Und ich esse zwar Fleisch, aber erschießen möchte ich es nicht unbedingt.
Direkt mit dem Silencer vorne drauf.
Was? Nochmal auf Deutsch, please.
Wenn man Millionär werden will, muss man was anderes machen. Ok, ich hab's doch verstanden.
Jedes Stück, das ich erlege, tut mir ein Stück weit auch mal leid, weil man einfach ein Leben ausgelöscht hat.
Schreckt.
Servus, ich bin Engelbert, ich bin Revieragmeister am Forstbetrieb Schliersee.
Ich bin 46 Jahre alt und es können Sie dabei sein, weil es sich lohnt, einen Tag mit dem Berufsjäger im Revier.
Jetzt sind es 5 Uhr.
Wann bin ich gestern ums Bett? Um 11 Uhr.
Boah, ok, da hast du was zu tun.
Dann, wie gesagt, um 4 Uhr aufsteht, um 5 Uhr ist man dann auf dem Ansitz.
Dann am Abend auch noch mal rausgeht um 7 Uhr und dann ist es oft 11 Uhr, bis man dann wieder zu Hause ist.
Und von dem her ist dann der Schlaf nicht so viel.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Gut, dann schauen wir mal.
Dann brauchen wir natürlich eine Waffe.
Bei mir sind es so eine 8 Langwaffe, das ist eigentlich so meine Standardwaffe.
Aber richtig schön fetten Schalldämpfer vorne drauf, auch gut so.
Ein Repetierer mit Schalldämpfer, nichts verschnörkelt, das ist eigentlich ein Arbeitsgerät, das gut funktioniert.
Wie? Der scopet oder was?
Das ist aber ziemlich noobig.
Quickscope only.
Der hardscopet.
Ich cringe, wer hardscoptet.
Gut.
Nein, Käse Kuchen, ich will irgendwie den Sensorstatus haben.
Parkplatz frei, Parkplatz nicht frei.
So prickelnd, aber das kann man sich ja auch nicht aussuchen.
Der scopet ja auch noch mit Silencer, das reduziert doch die Range, wissen wir doch alle.
Das Auto ist eine große Unterstützung, dass man die großen oder weiten Strecken in vernünftige Zeiten dann erledigen kann.
Eigentlich wissen wir alle, da brauchen Zweibein schwerer Lauf und Steady Aim, oder wie das hieß.
Nee, Steady Aim war das aus der Hüfte.
Zweibein, schwerer Lauf und wie hieß das? Wie hieß das andere, wo du besser scopen konntest?
Ja, den ACOG kann man auch machen.
Das Ziel ist für uns eigentlich heute klar die Jagdausübung.
Also wenn noch Möglichkeit, das Stück zu erlegen, dann schauen wir mal, ob sie wild sorgt und ob wir zu einem Erfolg kommen.
Man kann das selber machen, aber wieder etwas entdecken, immer wieder neue Facetten an der Natur kennenzulernen.
Und natürlich der Reiz der Jagd, das macht die ganze Sache dann natürlich spannend.
Stimmt, Stimmt. Ghost muss auf jeden Fall sein.
Außerdem hat er kein Ghillie-Suit an, das funktioniert schon mal gar nicht.
Die Augen, die wir immer offen haben, kann ja immer irgendwo was rum sein.
Die ist schon gut. Eine Kuh.
Vorne ist jetzt der kleine Sitz da, da schauen wir mal, ob wir gut hinkommen.
Der hat ja auch was wilder Typ hier jetzt.
Dann noch mal so 20 Minuten, halbe Stunde, schauen wir mal, was der Nebel so macht und ob wir einen Anblick kriegen.
Guck, der ist schon im Stells-Modus. Stells-Modus aktiviert.
Jetzt übt er erstmal sein Aim an der Kuh.
In der Stelle habe ich eigentlich alle drei Wildarten schon gesehen, also Reh-Wild, Rot-Wild und Kampfs-Wild.
Great Hiding Spots.
Für jede Wildart gibt es gesetzlich vorgeschriebene Abschusspläne.
Die Leistungsprämie, die müssen wir einsetzen.
Das ist das, was wir hier haben.
Also sprich, wenn du die passende KD hast, kriegst du Bonus.
Eine Art Urlaubsgeld.
Bei mir waren das heuer so 1600 Euro brutto.
Ich hätte wirklich jetzt die Hoffnung gehabt, dass er ein bisschen aufreißt, aber im Moment schaut es eher gegenteilig aus.
Naja, thermal visiert drauf. Easy.
Ich habe die Vorstellung, dass wir noch ein bisschen weitermarschieren.
Warum haben die aufgenommen, wie ihr atmet beim Laufen?
Das ist glaube ich so ziemlich die unsinnigste Audioaufnahme, die du da machen konntest.
Erst mal aufnehmen, wie ihr atmet.
Die Musik, als würde gerade etwas passieren.
Das ist ein Bech.
Der Nebel ist schon schwierig.
So ein Kampfs.
Stellzmodus.
Leute, der muss vorsichtig sein. Eins vorkillst du nicht.
Man sieht es, es sind sehr lichte Wälder.
Man will einfach den Wald wieder in die Höhe bringen, in den intakten Schutzwald.
Und da sind natürlich die Wildtiere und speziell die Kampfs in dem Bereich hinderlich.
Mit denen ist das schwierig, weil die natürlich die jungen Pflanzen da verbeißen.
Verbeißen?
Die nehme ich auch mal keine Scheiße. Scheiße, noch mal echt.
Und dann auf einmal läuft es halt nicht so und man empfindet dann einen gewissen Abschussdruck.
Und das stresst dann schon.
Abschussdruck, das ist ein cooles Fachwort, das könnte man sich für die Gamingwelt auch merken.
Da ist was.
Spotted.
Ist aber kein Hirsch, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber es sieht nicht aus wie ein Hirsch.
Jetzt wird hardscoped.
Also kalt lässt mich das nicht, also nach 15 Jahren noch nicht.
Es ist immer wieder eine gewisse Aufregung vor dem Schuss.
Erwischt.
Der Hund ist verwirrt.
Er hat wirklich alles gesehen, das runterputzeln des rechten Hundes.
Ja, ist gut gegangen, oder? Hat sich gelohnt.
Der Hund tritt komplett am Rad.
Weil das da unten ist ganz schön steil.
Beim Bergen vom Wild kann es auch mal gefährlich werden.
Also in die Richtung.
Last Nice, genau. Erst einmal 20 Minuten lang Blendgranaten schmeißen.
Da habe ich mich schon absichern müssen, weil man schon eher einen
gefahrenträchtigen Beruf ausübt.
Das kann schon sein.
Es kann sein, dass ihm mal ein großes Rast auf den Kopf fällt.
Also ich glaube, wenn wir draußen arbeiten, ist es gefährlicher als im Büro zu sitzen.
Da hast du was zu tun.
Jäger haben auch gewisse Traditionen.
Erstmal looten jetzt.
Man will auch dem erlegten Tier eine Ehre erweisen und dazu gehört.
Würde man dem erlegten Tier nicht die größere Ehre erweisen,
wenn man das nicht erlegt?
Dass man ihm einen letzten Bissen gibt.
Der Jäger selber kennzeichnet sich auch.
Kleiner Zweig.
Und dann einen Hutty.
Jede Stück, die ich erlege, tut mir ein Stück weit leid,
weil man ein Leben ausgelöscht hat.
Und berührt mich.
Jetzt brechen wir ihn auf.
Die Eingeweide bleibt da.
Wir brechen ihn auf, also er wird aufgeschlitzt.
Der Bruch bleibt da.
Alles klar.
Man sieht jetzt da schon die Leber.
Ich glaube, das ist mit die größte Werbung für unser Tun,
wenn wir einfach ordentlich Lebensmittel produzieren.
Das ist natürlich eine Entschädigung für das,
was wir als Arbeitsgerät einsetzen.
Das ist die Munition, die da entschädigt wird.
Also, da hast du schon einiges zu tun, Leute.
Da hast du schon einiges zu tun.
Ich meine, da geht es bergig hoch und runter.
Da musst du so ein Viech schleppen.
Also, Ultra-Pepo-Fett darfst du nicht dafür sein, um den Job zu machen.
Und wenn dann noch der Abschussdruck steigt, dann...
19,5.
Ja, da bin ich gut gelegen, gell?
Der muss jetzt 20 Kilo über den Berg tragen.
20 Kilo über den Berg tragen, da hast du schon...
Das ist doch eine sehr gesuchte Wildart.
Also, bei uns in der Region...
Also, da hast du schon ein bisschen was zu tun.
Danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Wenn du sagst, dass du...
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich habe durchwandert abgenommen.
Wir essen es also zu Hause auch ganz gern.
Oh, feiner.
Ich bin zufrieden, scheint mir.
Ein Hund.
Jetzt gehen wir raus, komm.
Jetzt gibt es Pepo-Fett, jawoll.
Erst mal ins bayerische Wirtshaus.
Ja, gut, dann machen wir Mittag.
Nee, doch nicht.
Die Wildbreite sind schon hoch.
Wir sind in der glücklichen Lage.
Meine Frau ist auch im Forstbetrieb als Försterin.
Wir haben dann auch noch das Glück, eine Dienststelle,
und dann haben wir auch noch das Glück, eine Dienststelle.
Wir wollen einfach ein bisschen Monitoring haben.
Hast du deine Emotes sprachgesteuert?
Ich habe ein paar ganz gute Fotos gelungen, muss ich sagen.
Hat mich auch gefreut.
Die Forsttribüne Spitzingsee,
wo meine Zuständigkeit eingebettet ist, hat 6000 Hektar.
Aber für 4400 Hektar bin ich jagdlich verantwortlich.
Hat er gesagt, wie viel er abschießen muss,
dass der Abschussdruck weg ist?
Was ist sein Soll?
Hat er das irgendwann erzählt und ich habe es überhört?
Ja, jetzt bin ich. Das ist eh einer.
Jetzt habe ich kein Glas mit dabei.
Das könnte der Adler sehen.
Das schraubt sich jetzt rauf.
Das mag ich jetzt aber nicht lieben.
Schauen wir mal, ob es da ein Bus hat.
Aber trotzdem schön.
Jetzt kontrollieren wir mal zuerst die Kamera.
Das wird immer ein spannender Moment.
Man will eigentlich ein bisschen wissen,
wie es die verschiedenen Wildarten geht.
Da ist ein Fuchs.
Wieder ein Fuchs.
Wieder einer.
Kein Adler, nein.
Bis jetzt habe ich ein ganz süßes Drauf.
Aber das wird ein Zufall sein.
Der hat da zufällig vorbeigeschaut.
Das Ding hat ordentlich viele Batterien drin.
Kein Adler dieses Mal.
Schade.
Ich lasse mich nicht gerne reduzieren auf das,
dass ich nur auf die Jacke gehe.
Das ist natürlich der größte Teil meines Berufs.
Aber ich finde es immer wieder spannend, so was auch zu machen.
Wenn man Millionär werden will,
muss man zu Hause auch was anderes machen.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Riech wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Brutto sind es 3600 Euro.
TV-ÖD E8 Stufe 5.
Das sind es dann so 2100, 2200 Euro.
Feierabend.
Wie viele Monatsgehälter?
Das wäre jetzt noch interessant.
Wahrscheinlich 12.
Das ist dann echt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Die Jacke lasse ich mir heute noch mal ausfallen.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir für uns selber noch was machen.
Das ist der Heizung- und Hobbyraum.
Da liegt eigentlich meine Winterleidenschaft.
Das sind meine Langlauf-Ski.
Wenn man so will, ist das ein bisschen mächtig.
Das ist ja nicht monatlich.
Das heißt immerhin.
Toast-Musik, Jenna.
immer noch tostmusik
ja chat glaube ich auch so viel natur da bist du bestimmt ausgeglichener und besser drauf als
ganzen tag im büro in der eck
das ist schon etwas abgesnipt weil es ist schon anstrengend dann muss man schon auf einiges dann verzichten das muss man schon ein bisschen abstimmen ich bin ja nicht nur ich allein, sie hat auch jagdliche verantwortung und geht selber auf die jagd und dann bin ich dann noch mal bei der kleinen daheim
so was kommt jetzt am ende raus ganz im ernst selbst wenn das jetzt nicht so viel ist in der summe wie man sich denkt wieviel kohle ist ich könnte mir vorstellen dass er tatsächlich besser drauf ist gesünder ist und insgesamt glücklicher als viele büro arbeiter
der beruf auch noch lange ausüben kann dass er auch zukunft hat der beruf ich könnte mir wie gesagt für mich nichts anderes vorstellen auch wenn ich kein millionär bin
so und am ende 200 euro im monat übrig also wie viel waren es jetzt inklusive weihnachtsgeld oder noch einen monat extra keine ahnung ja gut reich wirst du nicht davon aber
da ist das video von der försterin das mir sehr gut gefallen hat da gibt es noch weitere videos unbedingt anschauen da kann der kanal tja jetzt wissen wir auch was der jäger der revier jagd meister so macht
und es ist nicht nur skopen und snipen den ganzen tag parkplatz sensor zeig mal her ne das funktioniert das funktioniert wenn du einen eigenen parkplatz hast das funktioniert nicht du kannst so ein ding nicht einfach mitten auf die straße legen
ich will wissen ob die ob der parkplatz auf der straße frei ist der fachinformatiker den haben wir schon geguckt
und es ist auch viel zu teuer ich probiere das mal mit einem laser abstand sensor doch wenn du mir sagst mit was was sich geeignet ich meine ich kann einen microcontroller hinter das kellerfenster machen mir fällt aktuell bloß ein laser abstandsmesser eine billig webcam und das bild alle 5 minuten analysieren geht nicht
würde vielleicht auch gehen würde vielleicht auch gehen da kann ich eine esp 32 da kann ich eine esp cam unten hin machen da habe ich noch welche da
könnte man machen müsste man sich vielleicht mal überlegen esp cam bild abrufen und dann müsste man irgendeine kennt jemand eine gute library oder sowas fix und fertig wo ich image detection machen kann ob es ein auto ist und sowas
ja open cv musste ziemlich viel selber machen habe ich auch schon verwendet ich hätte gern am liebsten was da pump ich einfach das bild rein und er sagt mir am ende dann auto zu 95 prozent
auf der anderen seite image detection wird nicht gut funktionieren das auto steht ja nicht immer an der gleichen stelle und es ist auch teilweise nur ein stück vom auto zu sehen und ich glaube so ein laser abstandsmesser ist wirklich das beste
das nummernschild ist nicht zu erkennen mein kellerfenster ist an der seite also ich sehe das nummernschild von dort wahrscheinlich nicht das ist so ein typischer fall von mensch guckt aufs bild erkennt sofort dass sein auto davor steht image erkennt algorithmus weiß nicht
ja das kenne ich vielleicht andersrum straße erkennen person person person
da ist aber immer das objekt was erkannt werden soll komplett im bild und das ist bei mir mit dem mit mit
das müsste ich ausprobieren ob du wie gut das funktioniert
jetzt muss ich mal ausprobieren also erstens müsste ich mal eine esp camera im keller installieren um die autos zu erkennen
Und dann muss das Bild auch eine gewisse Zeit da sein, weil wenn einfach nur ein Auto
die Straße lang fährt, dann sollst du es ja nicht erkennen.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, so ein Laser Entfernungsmesser wird tatsächlich nicht
verkehrt.
Ach scheiß drauf, who cares?
Ich bin nämlich aus dem Kellerfenster in den Parkplatz, da erkennste noch nichts drauf.
Im besten Fall erkennst du die Waden von irgendwelchen Leuten auf dem Gehweg, die Waden oder die
Hose.
Also ich glaube so ein Laser Entfernungsmesser ist tatsächlich das beste.
Ihr seht, es ist gar nicht so einfach so was zu tracken.
Ultraschall wäre auch gut, aber Ultraschall geht nicht, weil Fenster davor.
Ultraschall Entfernungssensor, ja.
Bleibt eigentlich nur Laser, ja und bei Nebel und Regen, gucken zum Glück ist wenig Nebel
hier.
Der Parkplatz gehört mir nicht, das ist der einzige Parkplatz der mir gehört ist im Hof
und der ist natürlich immer frei oder da steht das Auto drauf, aber ich will halt, ich park
lieber auf der Straße vor dem Haus und da weiß ich halt nicht ob er frei ist und ich
hätte gerne einen Sensor, der mir das anzeigt bzw. im Zweifelsfall auch mal eine Push-Notification
schickt, dass wenn ich beispielsweise mich auf dem Weg mit dem Auto heim befinde, dass
mir da eine Push-Notification sagt, ey Parkplatz vor dem Haus frei, weil wenn nicht frei ist,
muss ich kurz in die andere Richtung auf den Parkplatz fahren, das ist auch nicht so weit
weg.
Lichtschranke geht nicht, weil da bräuchte ich ja irgendwas zum installieren draußen.
Das ist mitten auf der Straße, das ist ein bisschen auffällig oder?
Das bringt mir doch auch nichts, wozu, ich will nicht wissen ob mein Auto da drauf steht,
ich will wissen ob der Parkplatz frei ist, muss ich mir was überlegen, ich glaube Laser
Abstands Sensor, also entweder ein Laser Abstands Sensor oder eine Kamera mit Imageerkennung.
Ich glaube das geht beides, das ist tatsächlich Fivehead aber gibt es irgendwo Satellitenbilder
die im 15 Minuten Intervall aktuell sind, ich glaube nicht, dass man sowas als normalsterblicher
bekommt oder, gibt es Satellitenbilder, das wäre es Alter, Satellitenbilder, außerdem
was machst du wenn Wolken drüber sind, hast du auch gelitten, könntest du nicht einen
Lichtsensor, nee, ihr seht das ist nicht so einfach.
ja klar, ja, es läuft halt direkt hier vom Haus eine Straße vorbei und ich
fahre dann halt einfach nebenan und Park vor dem Haus, alles klar, Drohne drüber fliegen
lassen, das würde tatsächlich funktionieren, ein bisschen aufwendig oder, nee die Kellerfenster
sind genau auf Straßenhöhe, also da könnt ihr aus dem Kellerfenster könnt ihr wunderbar
alle Viertelstunde oder so ein Foto oder alle 5 Minuten ein Foto machen lassen mit einer
ESP-Cam von den, von sagen wir, so diesen paar Metern vom Haus die als Parkplatz in
Frage kommen und von da könnt ihr aber auch einen Laser Entfernungssensor nehmen, vielleicht
hast du dir so eine Spule in den Terrain, ist klar, Quatsch, steht nicht die Polizei
vor der Tür, das ist eine ESP-Cam im Keller, Kackel, das Wind soll das jucken, weil du
nichts siehst drauf und ich die Bilder nicht mal speicher, mir wäre es mit dem Laser Entfernungsmesser
aber auch besser als mit einer Kamera, Kamera stelle ich mir schwierig vor, ich glaube Laser
Entfernungssensor ist wirklich am besten, das muss ich mal ausbrechen, ich weiß halt nicht
wie gut die durch Fenster gehen, nee Chat, keine Ahnung, muss ich mal überlegen, ein
eventful day in the life of a Google Software Engineer, okay, Chat, Ratet mal, also ich kenne
das Video nicht, lass uns mal predikten, wie viel der Zeit des Tages er tatsächlich programmiert,
also ich tippe davon, dass es im Video so aussieht, als arbeitet er eine halbe Stunde
am Tag und der Rest ist Tisch, Kicker, Kantine, Fitnessstudio, Chillout oder sonst was, okay,
ist das ein Parodie-Video oder ernst gemeint, müssen wir mal gucken, warum macht Mental
Outlaw auf einmal Cooking-Videos, ah gut, wahrscheinlich kostet das Apartment schon
irgendwie 5000 Euro im Monat oder so, 10.30 Leute, Keckl, da bin ich schon zweieinhalb
Stunden am Arbeiten, eher dreieinhalb Stunden, das ist aber auch die Leute arbeiten dann
wahrscheinlich wieder bis 23 Uhr oder so, Warming-Up-Fingers, Moment, oh er arbeitet,
er arbeitet, Homeoffice er arbeitet, stellt euch mal vor, er arbeitet tatsächlich, Sachen
gibt es, und was macht er, so wie jeder gute Programmierer 90% der Zeit googelt, genauso
geht es, Fast-API ist das oder, ich erkenne es nicht genau, Fast-API könnte sein und rechts
von der Einrückung her kann das alles sein, ich wollte gerade sagen, vielleicht kann man
irgendetwas predicten, aber nee, keine Ahnung, das kann wirklich alles sein, ah, ayaya, Moment,
er watcht drei Animes parallel, sehe ich das jetzt richtig oder wie, I like to watch multiple
at the same time because those are super slow, der muss denn, okay das ist der Inbegriff
von Zoomer Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, Alter, 12.30 Uhr, okay er hat jetzt eine halbe Stunde
programmiert schon, nice, nice, nicht gestellter Chat, okay, jeder, okay, okay, okay, okay,
jeder, jeder Job ist 75%, Browser suchen und 25%, so das was ich auch immer sage, wer
denkt die krassen Hacker-Mans sitzen den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner und machen nur Hacker-Mans
Zeug auf der Tastatur, hat halt nichts mit der Realität zu tun, what, warum fährt er
doch auf die Arbeit, hä, wait a minute, der hat jetzt quasi 45 Minuten irgendwie gearbeitet
von daheim und okay, Alter, das wäre mir viel, viel zu aufwendig, du bist ja quasi
den halben Tag beschäftigt mit, mit Dingetrumme rummachen, Snacktime, ja was sonst, wird auch
nicht gearbeitet, jetzt, das hat er bestimmt nur hingeschrieben, weil er sonst geflamed
worden wäre, 16 Uhr, das Video ist nicht mal zu 11, 16 Uhr, da bin ich auf dem Weg
heim schon, 18 Uhr, Morgen, Kaius,
19.30 Uhr, what the fuck, was ist mit denen los, okay, ich meine, die
leben halt einfach da, ja, also nur mal so, dass ich es richtig verstehe, da ist um 20
Uhr, ungefähr 20 Uhr geht davon aus, das ist heftig, also, was hat er eigentlich schon
irgendwas gearbeitet, sinnvoll, er hat, ich glaube, er hat ungefähr eineinhalb Stunden
was gemacht den Tag über und er war acht Stunden am Start, ja gut, das ist bestimmt,
ich weiß nicht, so Einstellungs-Sache, ob einem das gefällt oder nicht, erst mal Muckis,
es ist 21 Uhr, Leute, es ist 21 Uhr,
da würde ich, da würde ich mitmachen, da wäre ich, da wäre ich sofort dabei, Leute,
es ist eine Stunde, bevor ich pennen gehe, 22.30 Uhr,
geht er, geht er irgendwann auch mal schlafen, what the fuck, Partytime unter der Woche,
was zum Teufel geht da ab, oder ist das Samstag oder Freitag, oder,
Alter, es ist, es ist mitten in der Nacht,
drei Uhr, okay, war das jetzt Samstag, oder war das ein wirklich normaler Tag in der Woche,
krasser Scheiß, also, ich weiß nicht, für mich wäre das nichts, und dann wieder, und
dann wieder aufstehen um 9.30 Uhr, übrigens, er hat kaum was geschafft an dem Tag,
also man hat kaum was gesehen, er hat irgendwie mal eine halbe Stunde, 45 Minuten im Homeoffice
was gemacht, dann noch mal irgendwie eine halbe Stunde oder 45 Minuten, Stunde vor Ort,
der Rest war Ping Pong, Fitnessstudio, ich weiß nicht, wie realistisch das ist, also
wenn das echt realistisch ist, dann wundere ich mich nicht, was, warum manche Google-Produkte
so sind, wie sie sind, und warum die Kommentarspalte teilweise auf YouTube so ist, wie sie ist,
keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, ich kann mich vorstellen,
dass es realistisch ist, aber gut, selbst wenn es realistisch ist, soll jeder machen,
was er will, ich kann es mir nur nicht vorstellen, dass das wirklich die Realität ist, die tun
immer so, als ist quasi das so ein einzig großes, spaßiges Erlebnis für so große
Softwarefirmen zu arbeiten, so nach dem Motto, du bist eins mit der Arbeit und bist glücklich
von morgens bis abends und du bist die Firma, die Firma bist du und ich weiß nicht, letztendlich
ist es doch genauso unrealistisch, wie wenn dir irgendwelche Firmen hier erzählen wollen,
so nach dem Motto, wir sind alle eine große Familie und wir mögen uns doch alle so, letztendlich
ist es das, um eigentlich nur mehr Kohle, mehr Geld mit den Leuten zu verdienen, hey,
wenn es so wäre, wäre doch cool, aber ich kann mir halt nicht vorstellen, dass es einem
Laden wie Google und Microsoft reicht, dass die Leute eineinhalb Stunden am Tag was Produktives
machen und in Wirklichkeit ist der Druck da wahrscheinlich noch höher, als es so wirkt,
das wirkt immer so nach spaßig und alles ist eine große happy, happy Familie und Reise
zusammen und so, in Wirklichkeit ist es wahrscheinlich gar nicht so, in Wirklichkeit ist es wahrscheinlich
knallharte belastende Arbeit, so nach dem Motto, hier du hast jetzt gefälligst das
abzuliefern, sonst fliegst du raus und das ist natürlich in diesen Videos nie zu sehen
und sicherlich auch mega Konkurrenz, ja garantiert, also, dass das alles so Friede, Freude, rum
gesummert ist zusammen, die ganze kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, ja, ich denke, das sind
im Prinzip alles so Art Werbevideos, es kann natürlich auch sein, dass die Leute, ich meine
die sind alle noch mega jung, dass sie da selbst noch drauf reinfallen und quasi diesen
Lifestyle dann abfeiern und irgendwie dann aber auch vielleicht mal in ein paar Monaten,
Jahren merken, dass das letztendlich wahrscheinlich nur dazu dient, sie noch mehr auszubeuten,
ja und die Hälfte hat man eh nicht gesehen, mir kann mir keiner erzählen, dass der nur
eineinhalb Stunden am Tag was sinnvolles Produktives macht, na gut, wie dem auch sei,
ja das kann ja alles sein, mit eineinhalb Stunden am Tag wirst du da nix auf die Reihe
kriegen, da kannst du selbst so Fivehead sein, wie du willst, guck mal, wie ich meine eigenen
Videos empfohlen kriege, das ist, das ist mit Sicherheit so, ja, das ist alles gefiltert
durch die Presseabteilung, bevor sowas rausgeht, obwohl es nicht Presseabteilung bei denen
heißt, sondern hat bestimmt irgendwelche super Fancy Namen, wisst ihr was mir an dieser
ganzen, dieser, dieser, dieser Kultur, die man in diesen Videos sieht, was mir daran,
was mir daran glaube ich missfällt und das liegt nicht, das liegt nicht an den einzelnen
Leuten oder so, die diese Videos machen oder so, gar nicht, zu denen kann ich ja überhaupt
nichts sagen, so diese, diese, diese Kultur, die man immer in diesen Softwareengineer Videos
gezeigt bekommt, sei es Google Software Engineer oder, oder Facebook Software Engineer, das
ist so diese, wie beschreibe ich das am besten, das ist so nach vorne hin Lachen und Happy
und Family und, und wir lieben uns alle und ich glaube diese ganze Sache hat, hat zwei
komplett gegen, zwei komplett unterschiedliche Gesichter, das ist eines diesen, dieses Lachen
und Happy, so nach dem Motto, Max mein Freund, hey zeig doch mal was hast du cooles programmiert,
oh ist das super und lass uns mal geiles Afterwork Meeting machen und yeah und alles ist super
und am anderen Tag kommt der gleiche Typ, äh, übrigens ich hab gesehen, du hast das
und das hier nicht richtig gemacht, wenn das noch mal passiert, schmeiß ich dich raus,
oder wahrscheinlich ist, wahrscheinlich ist es noch viel krasser, ich glaube das hat wirklich
zwei ganz extreme Gesichter parallel, diese, diese Welt, nur dass man, dass man diese eine
Facette halt nicht sieht in diesen Videos, ich mein das ist bei vielen Unternehmen hier
nicht ähnlich, nicht, nicht viel anders, ich hab das, guck mal jede Firma wird dir
erzählen, sie sind die geilsten und sie haben sich alle lieb und sonst wie und in Wirklichkeit
weißt du eigentlich genau, das ist alles nur Bullshit und Gelaber, ja, aber dort, die treiben
das, die treiben das echt, die treiben das echt auf die Spitze, glanz davon ab, ich
hab gar keinen Bock mit meinen Arbeitskollegen Tischtennis zu spielen, aber gut, das ist jeder,
soll jeder was er will, was er machen, was er will, ne aber ich glaube das hat wirklich
zwei krass gegensätzliche Seiten für sowas zu arbeiten, ja das ist so, das ist so auf
der einen Seite kriegst du erzählt, oh es ist alles toll, wir haben uns alle, wir haben
uns alle lieb und das ist die beste Firma und wir machen hier tolle Events und wir haben
die geilsten Produkte und so und dann auf der anderen Seite kommt raus, ja also ich hab jetzt
gesehen, deine Commits sind jetzt von 50 auf 40 runtergegangen, wir setzen jetzt den ganzen
Tag einen Performance Coach neben dich, der dich den ganzen Tag beobachtet und an mich
reportet, ob du auch ordentliche Sachen machst, das wisst ihr, so zwei Gesichter hat das bestimmt,
so auf der einen Seite, so nach vorne, so super nett und familial und freundlich, aber so
bald irgendwas ist, kriegst du wahrscheinlich so die komplette, das komplette Programm da
reingefahren.
Ey solang das freiwillig ist, ist das ja kein Problem, ich find's ja im Prinzip gut, wenn
Unternehmen beispielsweise sowas anbieten wie, dass du einmal die Woche in irgend so
nen, hatten sie bei uns auch mal probiert, in so nen Rückengymnastikkurs konntest, ja
bei uns haben die zweimal die Woche angeboten für Büroarbeitsleute, Rückengymnastik, irgendwie
halbe Stunde ging das glaube ich, halbe Stunde, für die 45 Minuten ging das, konntest du
dich anmelden für so Rückengymnastik zweimal die Woche oder halt zwei Termine die Woche,
fand ich eigentlich ganz gut, so wurde auch richtig gut, wurde auch richtig gut, richtig
gut angenommen, ähm ja, aber irgendwann hat man dann gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht mehr
wie das, wie das ging, am Anfang war das so, das war quasi in der Mittagspause, das war
glaube ich, ich glaube 12.30 Uhr bis 13.15 Uhr oder so, war das dieser Termin, so und
am Anfang war das kein Problem, da konntest du quasi Mittagspause machen und hast dann
halt, du hast halt quasi deine Mittagspause geopfert und hast dann halt noch 15 Minuten
hinten dran gehängt, was eigentlich Arbeitszeit wäre, aber da hat keiner was gesagt, so und
diese Kurse waren wirklich gut belegt, was auch nicht schlecht war, ein bisschen Rückengymnastik
auf der Arbeit machen gar kein Ding und irgendwann haben sie gesagt, nein, du musst ausstechen
vorher, also du musst dich aus dem Zeiterfassungssystem rausnehmen und seitdem ist keiner mehr hingegangen.
Also vorher war es halt so, du hast 25, 30 Minuten deiner Mittagspause geopfert für
Rückengymnastik und es war dann halt am Ende noch viertel Stunde, 20 Minuten Arbeitszeit
einmal die Woche, die wenigsten sind da zweimal hingegangen, was ich eigentlich sinnvoll
fand, weil es hat ja auch dafür gesorgt, dass du letztendlich gesünder bist, weniger
Krankheitstage hast, was auch immer, aber irgendwann kam dann einer aus der Big Strongs Abteilung
auf die Idee und hat gesagt, ne ne, bevor ihr da hingeht, müsst ihr, müsst ihr Zeiterfassung
ausstechen und seitdem sie das gesagt haben, ist halt keiner mehr hingegangen.
Man kann sich die Sachen halt auch zerstören, ja, ohje hör mal auf, moin Chaelor, ja und
ich glaube, das ist bei vielen dieser ganz großen auch so, ich meine nur, dass bei uns
jedes First-Person-View, na programmiert der hier wenigstens was, ja gut, das sieht auch
wie, das sieht wie gesagt am halbwegs normalen Arbeitstag aus, ups, na nochmal gucken wir
keins, ja ich kann den guten, ich kann den besten Bürostuhl empfehlen, den ich kenne,
der ist aber leider ein bisschen zu teuer, als dass ich ihn einfach so empfehlen würde,
ich hab einen, ich hab so einen, das ist der beste Bürostuhl, den ich kenne, ich hab schon
einige ausprobiert, das ist der beste Bürostuhl, den ich kenne, du kannst auch alle Teile als
Ersatz kaufen, du hast, du hast links, rechts, hinten, vorne, oben, unten, verstellbare,
Lehnen unabhängig voneinander, kannst die Härte der Lehne hinten einstellen, kannst
die Neigung einstellen, die Höhe einstellen, also wunderbar, leider ein wenig zu teuer,
also die Preise kannst du vergessen, ja, du kriegst den teilweise schon günstiger,
aber so 1200 Euro musst du halt rechnen, Schlafposition, du kannst es ziemlich weit
hinterklappen, aber drauf schlafen ist glaube ich nicht so geil, ne, also so 1200, 1300 Euro
musst du schon, musst du schon damit rechnen, aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist ein bisschen
wie mit, soll man sich einen ordentlichen Klo einbauen oder so, muss man überlegen
und gerade auch bei, bei einem Homeoffice, Büro, Arbeitsplatz, genau, wie lang sitzt
du da eigentlich drauf, also das rechnet sich dann auch schon, wenn du weniger Arsch weh
hast, wenn er weniger der Poppes weh tut, weniger der Rücken weh tut durch sowas, ja,
wie lange der hält, also ich hab den seit 2013 und der ist immer noch wie neu, genau,
ne also, also wenn sich zwei Sachen gelohnt haben bei mir hier im Haus, der ist nicht
made in China, der ist, der ist made in, kann ich dir sagen, made in, made in Dogan, ich
hab kein Blasenschema wo Dogan ist, Dogan, sind das Schweiz, ne, also das ist alle ziemlich
an der Schweizer Grenze, das ist ziemlich nah an der Schweiz, würde ich sagen, nah
an der Schweizer Grenze, ja, ne also kann ich, kann ich nur empfehlen und letztendlich
verdient man ja auch sein Geld damit, muss man, so muss man es auch mal sehen, ja letztendlich
verdient dieser Stuhl für dich auch, also du verdienst auf diesem Stuhl ja auch dein
Geld, also insofern ist es nicht verkehrt dich einen guten Bürostuhl zu kaufen, ich
persönlich würde einen guten Bürostuhl immer Gaming Stühlen vorziehen, Gaming Stühle
haben irgendwie keine Existenzberechtigung meiner Ansicht nach, außer dass sie cool
aussehen und viele denken, du hast ein super krasser sportlicher Gaming Stuhl, da bin
ich jetzt besser, ne, so YouTube nochmal die Chance uns was zu empfehlen, nope, no pass,
gibt's nicht, Software Engineer ranks Programming Languages, ok Leute wir skippen das komplette
Video und ich guck mir mal das Ergebnis an, ok hier, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ich seh
schon das JavaScript Gotttier ist, alter, also das guck mich nicht so, WTF, ok, wait a minute,
also lass mal schauen, Gotttier ist nur JavaScript und Timescript, alles klar, gefolgt von Pyson
HTML, ist das CSS, HTML, CSS, ist das ein Trollvideo oder was, was ist denn das, Power
Shell, was ist das für ein Logo Leute, irgendjemand Plan, das ist nicht Bash, das ist das Bash
Logo, das ist tatsächlich das Bash Logo, wusste ich gar nicht, ist das ein Witzvideo,
das ist, das ist, das ist ein Joke, das ist ein Witz oder, wahrscheinlich, Bash, wobei
ganz ehrlich, ganz ehrlich, ich stimme der Sache schon teilweise zu, allerdings nicht
wirklich so, naja gut, also was dieser Vogel ist weiß ich auch nicht, also ok, wo ich auf
jeden Fall zustimme ist, dass man JavaScript und Timescript oben einsortieren kann, dass
man Pyson oben einsortieren kann ja und meinetwegen HTML, CSS, lass ich mir auch noch gefallen,
Bash, ihr persönlich kennt mich, ich würde Bash auch weit oben einsortieren, weil ich
Bash mag, so, Woodcode in C++, käme bei mir auf jeden Fall komplett, bei Trash, Moment,
was machen wir jetzt, wie heißt diese Rank Me Seite, ne wie heißt das dieses Tier List,
Tier Maker, so was hat der dann sonst, also C Sharp wäre bei mir definitiv ganz oben
mit dabei, C++ ganz unten, Kotlin keine Ahnung, Rust würde ich eher auch für so General Purpose
Zeug, also ne, für alltägliche Sachen eher weiter unten einsortieren, Haskell, ne eher
nicht, MySQL, ja gut, passt sich so wirklich rein da jetzt, Go, ja tatsächlich Go würde
ich auch auf dieser Ebene einordnen, ich bin kein großer krasser Go Fan, auch wenn wir
letzten Zeit öfters mal was in Go gemacht haben, Ruby würde ich tatsächlich eins oben
drüber setzen, C würde ich wahrscheinlich so lassen, aber C++ kommt ganz weit unten
drunter, Visual Basic kommt weg, Java, tja, ich hab keine Ahnung von Java, ich würd's
im Zweifel verwenden, Lua, also so weit von dem wie ich das verteilen würde, ist das mal
gar nicht, es ist halt ein bisschen frontendlastig würde ich sagen, ja, also ich würde C Sharp
definitiv oben, zeig mal, zeig mal her, wir machen das neu, create your own ranking, auf
geht's, öh, öh, kann man das nicht, kann man das nicht resetten, kann man, kann man
das nicht machen, ja, natürlich ist das nicht scheiße, es geht schon denen als
ganz ehrlich in der heutigen zeit vielleicht für ganz für für kleinigkeiten und microcontroller sachen für für kleine optimierung sachen oder für
low power cpu auf mehr sp 32 aber normalerweise
wenn man es braucht ist nicht ist es gut dass man es machen kann aber ansonsten eher ziemlich
flüssig so
was fnt ist weiß ich nicht
go
ok ruby kommt auf jeden fall ruby kommt auf also normal also mein herz sagt ruby muss dahin
die sache ist plus die ach fnt ist fort dran die sache ist plus die ruby ist relativ useless geworden in letzten jahren über
rails ist auf dem absteigenden ast und ruby an sich hat auch ziemlich ziemlich wenig
Tja auftrieb aktuell deswegen würde ich mal würde ich mal hier auf die ähnliche sache eigentlich müsste man sind betier packen
also ich persönlich also mein persönliches empfinden ruby ist eine der besten und schönsten programmiersprachen die es gibt aber
vom nützlichkeitshalt faktor aktuell halt bisschen weniger so pap ist absolut in ordnung
Javascript auch absolut in ordnung sie schabt kommt bei mir auf jeden fall da oben hin tatsächlich wird javascript auch da oben hin packen
Rust ja irgendwie hier so
ja
ich würde auch in die gleiche kategorie packen
java ich habe keine ahnung von java das ist halt das ding
für mich ist es halt hier weil ich damit nichts anfangen kann
go würde ich tatsächlich auf eine
go würde ich mal hier so hin packen
Haskell gibt es bei mir nicht visual basic braucht kein mensch was ist das phoenix oder was ist das ne swift ist das oder swift
swift swift
alles was ich von swift gesehen habe ist in ordnung
lua braucht kein mensch
also sprachen wo erase mit eins anfangen ist schon richtig sass
C würde ich auch auf die sache packen C++ ja man kann es man kann es verwenden
ganz ehrlich eigentlich realistisch betrachtet müsste ich so machen weil
von von dem wie ich den kram verwendet aber C ist ja irgendwie in sich in sich logisch aber C++ ist halt abfuck
eigentlich eigentlich müsste ich so machen weil gerade was was microcontroller zeug verwendet
du musst halt C++ und ich meine ich komme damit ja auch halbwegs klar mittlerweile, aber
ich hasse die sprache halt komplett als so wirrer wirrer
Crap ist was ist denn das?
lisp oh gott
Ich würde es tatsächlich als in der hier ganz ehrlich auch krempel
Was ist das das ist Css
Wenn Css ist dann packen wir das mal
Ja dml und Css ja gut das müssen wir auch hier rein packen aber ich mag Css nicht
Css ist pains champ es ist
Css ist ein
ist in der tats ziemlich gut aber ich habe kein plan von p outfits ich war täglich im ton
P Fotos
Ja und ja ich mag Css aber ich mag es ist ich mag front Netherlands
tja für die Leute die noch nicht Hochschule ig
Tja, für die Leute, die das damit machen, so in der Richtung, ungefähr würde ich das
wahrscheinlich ranken, wobei der TypeScript fehlt.
Also, ja, so ungefähr würde ich das ranken, wahrscheinlich.
Hat jeder so seine Geschmäcker.
Okay, dann erzählen uns, was ist Go-Worst-Features?
Okay, jetzt haben wir das Video geguckt, jetzt empfiehlt uns das YouTube nicht mehr.
Easy fix, weil ich bin nicht eingeloggt und ich kann nicht sagen, ignore.
Ist das eine Xbox?
Was krass getunte Xbox.
Case Modder, die Xbox.
Okay, Leute, das gucken wir uns jetzt auch nochmal an, mal gucken, wie es im Vergleich
ist zu Google.
Auf geht's.
Also, der steht schon mal 7.30 Uhr auf, das ist schon mal eine Zeit, die kann ich irgendwie
nachvollziehen.
Erst mal schön beim Zähneputzen zugucken, jawoll.
Ich mach mal die Musik ein bisschen leiser, die braucht man da eh nicht bei.
Naja, 8.10 Uhr wäre ich wahrscheinlich gerade, also früher, früher bin ich ja so früh gefahren,
ich bin nicht um, also früher bin ich ja 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden, dass ich irgendwie 7 Uhr,
wann war ich denn da?
Weißte kann ich nicht mehr, wann ich genau auf der Arbeit gewesen bin.
Kann ich euch sagen, guck mal, ich hab doch auf Twitter, Twitter, Moment.
Ich hab doch damals ein Video gepostet, wo ich über die Brücke gelaufen bin.
Frankfurt bei Nacht, hab ich doch mal gepostet.
Frankfurt bei Nacht, okay keine Ahnung, find ich nicht mehr, weil ich das gepostet hab,
dann weiß ich, wann ich, wann ich da bin.
Naja, zumindest, mittlerweile steh ich eher, steh ich eher 7.30 Uhr auf, dass ich so,
sag mal, spätestens um neun, wenn ich nach Frankfurt muss, auf der Arbeit bin.
Wenn ich Homeoffice mache, steh ich auch 7 Uhr sonst was auf und bin dann 7.15, 7.30
Uhr fang ich an.
Aber der muss anscheinend auf die Arbeit fahren, okay.
Läuft ja zum Bus quasi, oder, ja.
Also seit ungefähr ne Stunde Anfahrt, seh ich das richtig?
Mal gucken, wann er da ist, mal gucken, wann er da ist.
Die Musik, Alter.
Okay, ja, also ungefähr ne Stunde, würd ich sagen, ungefähr ne Stunde hat der, hat
der Weg zur, zur Arbeit.
Deckt sich, glaub ich, mit dem, was hier auch viele haben.
Ja, also ne Stunde, also ne Stunde vom Haus verlassen zu ins Büro reingehen.
Das Ding bräuchte von den Farben her bräuchte Google eindeutig diesen Automat.
Ja, Vitamin C ist klar, ist klar, als bringt das irgendwas.
Das ist wenigstens mein realistischer Task, das mach ich auch meistens, wenn ich morgens
neu anfange, erst mal E-Mails gucken, heißen Ställs, der Chat fragt, warum sind das eigentlich
immer Asiaten?
Das liegt ganz einfach daran, weil Asiaten Fiveheads sind, Asiaten sind high IQ, die
können sowas.
Meeting Room, okay, wichtig, dass man für ein virtuelles Meeting auf die Arbeit fahren
muss, enorm wichtig.
Okay, also, der hat tatsächlich, wenn ich das richtig sehe, um 9.15 Uhr angefangen
und bis 11.30 Uhr gearbeitet, wie jetzt, wirklich, die Arbeiten, das sah in dem Google
Video aber noch anders aus.
Ja, wie die es schaffen, den ganzen Tag mit ihrem Notebook zu arbeiten, verstehe ich auch
nicht.
Ich brauche Maus und Tastatur, es geht sogar so, wenn ich mich auf die Arbeit, wir haben
ja mittlerweile auch so Halbpix, also wenn ich nach Frankfurt fahre, auch so die Möglichkeit,
also nicht fest am Büro, am gleichen Platz zu arbeiten, sondern auch in irgendwelche Meeting-Räume
umzuziehen oder an anderen Arbeitsplatz umzuziehen, wenn ich da irgendwas mache, ich nehme immer
die Tastatur und die Maus mit, ich kann nicht mit Notebook, Trackpad und Notebook-Tastatur
gescheit arbeiten, ich kriege das nicht hin.
Okay, wir sehen schon mal, der hat jetzt schon mehr gearbeitet als der ganze Google Typ
den ganzen Tag.
Okay, Daily Meeting, blablabla, übrigens eine Sache, was ich dort auch relativ spannend
finde, wir haben jetzt ja schon einige dieser Daily Live, Daily Software Engineer geguckt,
die sind zwar öfters mal am Meeten, aber nie so viel wie bei uns und nie so ausführlich.
Wie gesagt, ich habe Tage, da fange ich um 9 Uhr an, bin um 15 Uhr fertig mieten, weil
es irgendwie acht verschiedene Meetings gibt, die dann irgendwie von einer halben Stunde
bis eineinhalb Stunden gehen und die müssen halt noch was arbeiten in der Zeit, die können
ich den ganzen Tag mieten.
Was ich auch gerne machen würde, also arbeiten und nicht mieten, aber, also guckt mal, der
hat um 9 Uhr angefangen und hat von 9 bis 12 gearbeitet jetzt, mein Meeting ist ja auch
Arbeit.
12 Uhr futtern, normale Zeit, dort kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Das erscheint mir deutlich realistischer zu sein als der Krempel, den wir bei dem Google
Video hatten, Alter, ist das ein riesen Ding oder, wenn du überlegst, das ist alles Facebook
gehört, krass oder, Alter, diese Musik, richtige Zuma-Music, Alter, jetzt wird hier gedubstappt,
Alter, das ist so, ah, kein Zoomer hört das, okay, wer hört denn so was dann?
Jemand, der Copyright-free Musik braucht, ja, das stimmt wohl, okay, er geht Mittagessen,
passt, verstehe ich, Mittagessen muss sein, was hat er denn, Chicken Wings Sushi, beste
Kombi, Sushi, Chicken Wings, könnt ihr auch ganz nachfuddern, Wasabi, ja, okay, ich bin
auch ein bisschen schäumlich, aber, okay, er hat eine Stunde Mittagspause gemacht, er
arbeitet dann weiter, er arbeitet den ganzen Tag fast, stellt euch mal vor, Google, guckt
euch das mal an, was, Afternoon, 13 Uhr, ja gut, ist Afternoon, ist zwar nicht Abend,
aber Afternoon, okay, jetzt ist 17 Uhr, jetzt würde ich normalerweise wahrscheinlich so
langsam aber sicher mal heimfahren, ich meine, der hat angefangen um neun, acht Stunden sind
jetzt rum, okay, Mittagspause, okay, aber trotzdem so langsam aber sicher, wenn ich jetzt mal
auf dem Heimweg, die Musik ist wirklich richtig MonkaS, Alter, diese Musik, okay, das ist
nice, kostenloses Eis, Leute, wenn ich kostenloses Eis auf der Arbeit hätte, dann hätte ich
nicht abgenommen, dann wäre ich dreimal dicker noch, Peppofett wäre ich aber richtig Peppofett,
gibt's kostenloses Eis bei uns, weiß gar nicht, ist das kostenlos wahrscheinlich, ey ist doch,
das ist doch mal ein normaler Arbeitstag, das ergibt doch Sinn, der hat neun Uhr angefangen,
hat acht Stunden gearbeitet, bisschen weniger, so 37 und dann fährt er heim und er hat von
diesen sieben Stunden, da hat von diesen acht Stunden anscheinend auch vier, fünf Stunden
was Sinnvolles gemacht, man kann ja nicht vier, fünf Stunden erwarten, dass jemand konzentriert
programmiert, das funktioniert ja nicht, ja, der hat organisatorische Sachen gemacht, der
hat Meetings gemacht, irgendwie die Daily-Geschichten gemacht, das sieht nach einem ganz normalen
sinnvollen Arbeitstag aus, ich mein, er ist nicht ins Fitnessstudio gegangen, er hat kein
Ping Pong gespielt mit seinen Arbeitskollegen, er hat keine Konsole gespielt, er hat keine
komischen Karaoke-Dinger gemacht mit seinen Arbeitskollegen, wie der bei Google, aber
er hat halt was geschafft.
Das war doch mal wirklich was realistisches, so ungefähr sieht ein normaler Arbeitstag
aus, nicht nur bei Facebook, an vielen Stellen, ja, aufstehen, zur Arbeit fahren, sinnloses
Scheuchel auf der Arbeit machen, wieder heimfahren, aber dass Facebook da so ein komplett riesen,
riesen eigenes Gebiet hat, mit Eis und sonst was drauf, gut, ich mein, Facebook kann sich
leisten, nee, ich mach garantiert kein Day in the Life of Wobblers, nee, nee, man darf
von abgesehen, ich dürfte da gar nichts filmen, außerdem sieht man dann, wo ich arbeite und
da kann ich im Stream nicht mehr lästern, auch blöd.
Rust in 10 Minuten, alles klar, ja, es ist überhaupt nicht recreated, da fehlt bestimmt
das gesamte Game, ich mein, Mario World hatte, glaub ich, 130 Level oder so, das hatte saumäßig
viel, das ist glaub ich eins der umfangreichsten Mario Games, die es je gegeben hat, was das
angeht, und nicht, dass man das nachgebaut hat in Mario Maker.
Tja, gibt es sonst noch irgendwas, was wir gucken müssen, chat, ich krieg langsam Hunger,
muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich krieg langsam Hunger, ich glaube, ich ess jetzt was, chat,
ich glaube, ich ess jetzt was, und vielleicht machen wir nachher endlich dieses Go Programm
fertig, dass das mal abgehackt ist und wir noch ein bisschen Go lernen.
Weltweiter kleinster Laster, Laser, nicht Laster, Entfernungsmesser, ja, ich weiß halt nicht,
wie weit das geht, also meine Frage ist ja, wie weit gehen die Dinger und vor allem gehen
die gut durch Scheiben durch.
Was, hier geht nix, ich geh jetzt auf, ich geh jetzt was essen, ich hab Hunger, Pepofat,
doch heute Abend machen wir wahrscheinlich das Go Programm endlich fertig.
Wir sehen uns, machts gut, bis dann Leute, CU.